well here i am tonight with fifteen
hundred dollars for one of our couples
and if any of them say the secret way
the duck will fly down
and pay him a hundred and one dollars
that's true
we've made a we've been obliged to make
a substantial increase in the amount of
the
secret word we have to recognize that
there are other shows and
television now that are giving away much
more substantial sums and we decided
that
the only way we could fight fire was
with fire so we've raised the secret
word
from the customary hundred dollars to
101 okay now
all right on your way peter legrancho
just before we went on the air our
studio audience selected mr william
weber to be on the show
and his partner is a special guest mrs
heilbrunner
mrs heilbroner of weber and heilbronner
i have no idea you rarely do george
i wanted to tell you about this young
lady that i invited the show merely
because she happens to be a friend
of mine you have a friend yes uh her
name is
uh miss claudia morimoto oh
and i'd like mr weber miss morimoto to
come in right now please
uh right now well welcome welcome to you
bet your life
say the sacred word and you'll divide
101 it's a common word something you
find around the house
claudia morimoto eh and you're a friend
of feminines
how old are you claudia seven seven
huh well you're a right cute looking
girl man
you seem like such a bright little girl
claudia how was it you're a friend of
feminines
where did you know george i you in the
same grade at school no
i met him on the airplane and were you
the hostess
no i saw him and then uh
i didn't know if it was really him and
it was him and so i was talking to him
and then
and then my daddy came so i had to go to
the back
for refreshments and then you got to go
back
for refreshments
well how did you meet mr fennerman i was
talking about his coat when he went past
or something no
no i just walked by and then i saw him
oh what do you think of mr fenneman is
he pretty funny
yes i think he's would you say he's
funnier than i am
no i think you're funny than all right
i'm glad you said that claudia mr
fennerman is glad you said that too
you know it isn't easy to find work in
the middle of the season
these jobs don't grow on trees you know
unless you're a gorilla
do you think mr fenneman is handsome yes
i think he's happy
you do you think he's handsomer than i
am
yes
well you can't have everything like that
beauty and talent i guess just too much
to ask
you know i have a little girl about your
age melinda she's nine
and i know how she spends her day now
now tell me how do you spend
your day what do you like to do best of
luck well i read some books
you said the sacred words so you
you and your friend here each get uh is
fifty dollars and fifty cents for you
and uh and his uh fifty dollars and 50
cents for you
thank you now out of it
and you're uh bill webber yes sir how
did you get on the show who are you a
friend of
nobody come
now you must have some friends
what sort of uh uh work do you do well
i'm a buyer in the office of the
purchasing agent of the city of los
angeles
that sounds like a pretty imposing job
but just what do you purchase
well everything from soup to nuts
you've been over buying i think
there's one thing this town doesn't need
is more nuts
i think we have enough even for nevada
well i presume you buy stationery for
the city and muselage and water coolers
and things like that but
what are some of the unusual things you
buy could you give us an example
well recently we bought an elephant and
the uh some ladybugs for the park
department
ladybugs and an elephant didn't you buy
any uh
gentlemen bugs for the ladybugs well
actually it seems like a pretty cruel
thing to do doesn't it all ladybugs
aren't ladies some of them are men bugs
too
how much did you pay for the ladybugs
well they're about 10 for a penny
that's cheap enough for ladybugs makes
an ideal gift for the man who has
everything
well i'd like to go on talking to you
too but it's time to play your bet your
life you don't want to sing as a little
japanese song before we go into the game
man
no okay well then we play uh
play the game claudia you're pretty
young to take part in a quiz
is your mother in the audience where is
she over there
mrs morimoto would you come up here
please
mrs morimoto would you mind standing in
for claudia on our quiz
i'd be glad to all right claudia and mr
webber you selected small towns and
cities of the us i'm going to list six
cities and towns all in the same state
and you tell me in what state they're
located
and remember the more the question is
wait the harder it is
now you can start with 10 20 50 80 000.
what do you want to start with we'll go
for 100 100.
here are the towns and cities elk point
lake andes deadwood mound city and
aberdeen
what state are they in south dakota
that's right south dakota is right
[Applause]
on your way i have two hundred dollars
that's a pretty tough question
now what are you going to go for
all right double springs phoenix city
with tonka
muscle shows and grove hill
double springs phoenix city with tonka
muscle shoals and grove hill
tennessee no you were close it's alabama
you uh lost half your 200 you still have
one hundred dollars all right now what
are you going to try
80 here are the towns and cities
skowhegan
with wiscasset south paris vanguard
and milan knockout what is the state
next to last one
banger b-a-n-g-o-r that'd be mean
mean that's right that's maine that's
right
[Music]
you now have 180 you're going to go for
70 you've got a pretty sharp partner
there
here are the towns and cities lady smith
green bay
baraboo rhinelander friendship in
washburn wisconsin
wisconsin on wisconsin is right
and you line up with 250 claudia don't i
get a kiss
right here attaboy i'll get you later
mrs moreno
well thanks and good luck from the
desoto plymouth
the time has come it's very clear the
car you've wanted is
really here it's delightful it's the
love
[Music]
car is falling about you can hear that
great big engine murmuring floor
oh there you go so make sure you see
and drive the new d soda wide man alive
it's delightful it's
[Music]
tomorrow at your desoto dealers see and
drive the delightful the lovely desoto
for 1956.
[Music]
miss roberta carol and mr rafael
brandies are waiting to talk to you so
folks your queen please and meet
rachel marks welcome for the desoto
plymouth davis say the sacred white and
divide 101.
it's a common way the common word
something you'll find around the house
roberta carol
and rafael brandees roberto are you
married
no i'm not now you're talking in that
case let's find out all we can about you
are you engaged no age 21
right five eight eyes green
hair brown hair very good
legs two
that's right two
where are you from roberta well i was
born in long beach and then moved to
west hollywood and i
live in north hollywood now you're a
ralph uh brandees
raphael oh raphael yeah are you any
relation of the former supreme court
justice
no i wish i were he's puzzling
b-r-a-n-d-e-i-s and had no eye in mind
well you see you jumped at conclusions i
wasn't referring to him
are you in relation to that other
supreme court justice william howard
taft
there again i'm missing oh where are you
from raphael
originally in new york city where i got
my education little war stint
columbia university and ryan oh
you must have been there around the time
of uh rogers and heart and oscar
hammerstein and the same time
what did you uh study there what did you
anything in particular or just
no i became a lawyer practiced for 16
years in new york
well uh are you married raphael yes 31 a
half years
31 years of marriage and you can't be
much of a lawyer then
seems to me in 31 years you could have
found some kind of a loophole
roberta that's uh pretty formal uh what
do your friends call you
robbie robbie do you have a job robbie
no i'm a student at usc oh you're still
going to school
yes senior yeah i was i was [ __ ] laude
there you know
in fact i was so loudy they asked me not
to come back
do you live on the campus or do you live
at home i live on the
on the campus in a sorority house you
like living in a sorority house
very much it's a wonderful place to live
i'd like to try it sometime
are some of the important rules that you
girls break around your house
well the university has set up a curfew
of course
and uh this means that the girls have to
be in at 10 15
monday through thursday friday night and
saturday night at two
and sunday night at 12 in the morning
two in the morning
you're allowed to stay until two and a
half yes those are date nights you see
parties and that sort of thing and um
panhellenic has set up a ruling that
alters this plan
if the girl has a scholarship rating
over a b average or an 85
which is about the same thing some of
the girls are 85
now if they have an average of over 85
or b average then they can stabilize the
average guy i go out with is about 85.
if they have an average of 85 they start
with midnight
they can stay out until midnight monday
through friday tuesday until 2 o'clock
in the morning
this is monday through thursday they can
stay until 12 if they have over a b
average well if anybody's going to keep
it till midnight she also needs a
perfect 36
24 36 average isn't she
well you're a nice couple and you have a
lot in common and my advice is get
married
right away now let's play your bet you
like remember to start you off with a
hundred dollars miss a question and you
lose half your bankroll
is that clear in the race for the one
thousand five hundred dollars the first
couple won two hundred
fifty dollars and the secret word is
book
you selected the musical category these
are all top tunes of the last 20 years
remember the more the question is right
the harder it is
now what do you want to start with 10 50
up to 100.
90 all right jerome kind dorothy fields
and jimmy mchugh
collaborated on this song that was
featured in the show roberta
you tell me the title of it okay
[Music]
what is it what's the name of it i don't
know
it's from roberta what is the title
looking at her you should have known the
title it's a lot better to look at
well you still have fifty dollars all
right now you've still got a long ways
to go what are you going to try this
time
80 70 60
10 80. be fine all right 80 this song is
from a big broadway musical let's see if
you can identify it play jack
[Music]
now what are you going to try for things
are picking up
this song was written by rodgers and
hammerstein and it's from the picture
picture state fair what is the name of
it okay jack
[Applause]
it is your last chance to beat the other
couples now do you want to go to another
plateau
well there wouldn't be a pleasure okay
what are you going to go for 70 you
haven't had 60
15. 70. all right everybody 70
matt gordon and harry warren wrote this
song for the picture hello frisco hello
give me the title of it
[Music]
what is the answer
[Music]
well you're awfully close but they won't
give it to you
it's you'll never know you were playing
with it well you wound up with half the
230 you wind up with 115 dollars well
thanks and good luck from the soda
plymouth dealers sorry didn't win more
uh we have a couple of men waiting to
talk to you now
mr percy meek and mr emerit ashford
gentlemen when you come in please and
meet groucho marx i'm sure you'll get
along
welcome welcome to the soda plymouth
dealer say the secret word and divide
100
101 it's a common way something you find
around the house
emmett ashford hey we're glad to see you
emma how do you do that
how do you do for the benefit of people
who don't know emmett's one of the most
respected and capable umpires in the
pacific coast league
[Applause]
emmitt i understand you may go up to the
majors next year is there any truth to
this
rumor well gosh garcia show there's been
rumors but uh
quite a lot of smoke but i haven't heard
anything definite and uh of course it's
my ambition like everybody else i've
seen you um firing a lot of games this
year emmitt are you aware of that
yes and i've seen you too now that's
ridiculous how could you possibly see me
clear up in the grandstand when you
can't even see a strike
six inches from your nose my job i heard
you on several occasions
i'm only kidding emma you're one of the
best umpires in baseball
i'd say you don't miss more than five
out of six
how old are you m 39 39
are you married no ambassador
well don't be too smug now even an
umpire can strike out on some fast
curves
damn it you just dust off your plate for
a minute i want to talk to your partner
over here
by the way why do you always turn your
back towards the outfield
when you're dusting off the plate is
that for reasons of safety
it can be dangerous i uh have found out
though as
uh someone uh should inadvertently
advise the pitcher to now
has it ever happened to you
no thank you and uh your name is percy
meek
that's right i've heard a lot about you
mr meek aren't you going to come into a
lot of real estate one of these days no
they're not
well that's strange i've always heard
that the meek she'll inherit the age
i think that's a mispetition well pisces
judging from that cowboy outfit you're
wearing i'd say you were an insurance
salesman am i correct
no sir well uh are you a cowboy
yes sir or which kind drugstore
television or real
well i guess you'd call me real camera
real cowboy you mean you've actually
seen a cow
where are you from place paramount or
republic studios
oklahoma oklahoma studios is that in
town here
no i didn't see any studios there have
you ever been on a horse
oh a few times what are you doing here
shouldn't you be heading him off at the
pass
hardly huh what kind of work you do
place are you still punching cows
sometimes now why do you punch the cows
do they have a punch back
well not so far they have it huh not so
far
why do they call it punching cows you
know
no no you're really a bag of information
well tell me a place he has a real blown
in the bottle cowboy what do you think
of the cowboy movies on television you
know like
hoot gibson and tom mix and
bill heart and convoy bronco billy
anderson
oh i guess they're all right but i never
can understand why they don't run out of
ammunition they can shoot 15 or 20 times
without reloading
then when they get they get reloaded but
this is after the picture is over
and i never can understand why they ride
away and leave the girl they never did
that way when i was a boy
well they uh some of them are married
you know
well it couldn't be emmett one of the
reasons the crowd always likes to watch
you working a game is because in
addition to being a good umpire you put
on quite a show
now why are you so dramatic i saw you
down in phoenix you know when
derosia was down there with the giants
against cleveland last year
well um you're pretty fancy down there
you were doing some pretty fancy sweeps
there
well uh i've asked that question quite a
lot of times groucho but
all i can answer is that it's just the
way i feel within myself
a man is either hotter safe and there's
no in between
and the more emphatic you make it the
better off it is for everyone concerned
there's never any doubt in your mind
about a decision not mine
well uh let's see you in action let's
say you're behind the plate and i'm the
manager of the home to you now
if i see you go sit in the bleachers
then now emmett pretend it's the last of
the ninth inning
score is tied and a runner tries for
home okay here comes the throw he's
sliding now what is it emmett
and god
out you robin and begin with the catch
and drop the ball
damn it that was as miserable a decision
i've ever seen
now if you want to win some money in the
quiz you better take another look
okay here comes the runner now there's
the throw what is it emmett
hey see you have to know how to handle
an umpire
you have to be just as crooked as they
are
haven't put it there the mages don't
grab you next season the police will
i predict you're going to be in the big
leagues inside of another year you'll be
a sensation up there too
thank you enough about baseball and
cowboys let's get down to some serious
business and play your bet your life
in the race for the one thousand five
hundred dollars the first couple still
leads with two hundred fifty dollars
now one answer between you on everything
you selected sports
why am it you dating crook
[Music]
i thought you were gonna take something
like fan dancing isn't it
remember the more the question is worth
the harder it is now uh what do you want
to start with
10 20 50 100.
uh 100 100. what do you call the system
of betting where all bets are recorded
and the odds are determined by the
amount wagered by the bettors
uh very mutual perry mutual is right
[Applause]
you now have two hundred dollars barry
mitchell used to be perry cuomo now what
are you going to go for now
well 90
90 90 now bob richards was the 1952
olympic champion in what track event
oh you don't care anything about him
pole vaulting is right huh
[Music]
you now have 290 why don't you stick
your horn in there cowboy
all right what are you going to go for
80 80 80. in golf what do you call the
score
for a whole played in two under par
two on department yeah
no it's an eagle i just i was gonna say
birdie but it wasn't a birdie
you now have 145 dollars all right now
don't get discouraged you still got a
way to go
you want to go for 70 right
all right floaters sinkers and knucklers
are terms and what's forever
[Music]
baseball pitches is absolutely right
[Music]
[Applause]
dollars in just one minute get the
chance at the one thousand five hundred
dollar question
and now groucho our next guest is a
powerful one
the new 1956 desoto
and when i say powerful i mean powerful
the tremendous new desoto fireflight
engine
has 255 horsepower
that's right 255 horsepower
under this beautiful hood is a
tremendous new v8 engine
it's bigger and it's a new high
compression engine
it also has a new and far superior 12
volt electrical system
for higher ignition and much greater
performance
well what do all these technical details
mean to you
well they mean that your beautiful new
desoto will breeze over the steepest
hills
start off like a champion sprinter
and give you terrific new acceleration
in every driving range
particularly in the passing range so
vitally important for safe driving in
modern traffic
in addition the new desoto also has
brand new braking power
an entirely new kind of brake that works
far better
a bigger brake with more reserve power
and longer wear
that means safer driving for you
tomorrow
see and drive the car that brings new
power
new performance new safety and new
beauty to the medium price field
the car that's delightful to drive be
lovely to see the delightful de lovely
desoto
for 1956.
[Music]
and here are claudia morimoto and mr
webber and
claudia's mother the winning trio all
set for the
1 500 question
all right here we go for 1 500 i'll give
you 15 seconds to decide on the single
answer between you think happening
please no help in the audience
a song by john howard payne featured in
the opera clary
the maid of milan is known the world
over
for one thousand five hundred dollars
what is the name of this well-known song
one of the most famous songs in the
whole world the
name of the composer is john howard
payne p-a-y-n-e
[Music]
what is the ants you two decided upon
you don't know guests
take a guess you shouldn't know that we
do
you should know it it's home sweet home
[Music]
well i'm sorry so that means the big
question next week will be worth two
thousand dollars
well they lost the big money how much
they win the quiz george i won 250
in the quiz well congratulations and
thanks to all of you and to all of our
contestants on the show tonight
and here he is the one the only
what a bounder oh that's me
well here i am again with three thousand
dollars for one of our couples
if any of you say the secret word the
duck will fly down and pay him a hundred
dollars
the way the night is chair on the lamb
duck
mr fennerman proceed with the
inquisition all right rachel first
tonight we have
mr bert stewart who has some interesting
experiences he'd like to tell you about
his partner is a special guest mrs edgar
r hill
and here they are folks you come in
please and meet groucho marx
welcome welcome for your bet your life
say the sacred word and uh
for the disorder plymouth dealer say the
sacred word and divide a hundred dollars
it's a common word
something you find around the house
assuming that you have a house
mrs hill i'll start with you where are
you from mrs hill
i am originally from chicago i was born
on mortgage avenue on the south side of
chicago oh
on the banks of the wabash i used to
live in calumet in the 46th
are you familiar with that neighborhood
yeah they ran us out of there now
phenomenon
says you're a special guest is is that
because you were born in chicago or do
you have some other distinction
well no i i think it's probably because
i'm the
mayor of newport beach california mayor
well your honor we're honored to have
you here
yeah i should imagine the lady mayor is
fairly rare were you elected in a
smoke-filled room or a perfume-filled
room
no i i was just elected in the ordinary
way and
it just happens in our city the
councilman polling
the largest number of votes is named
mayor by
the remainder of the council well you're
a pretty cute looking mayor you know
thank you the average mayor doesn't look
that good i've heard that you have a
major problem with teenagers every year
at newport beach
do you have any comments to make about
the gay parties that go on down there
well i don't know it seems that every
year
during easter vacation the um teenagers
of
all of all southern california i think
they ought to
go down to balboa which is a part of
newport beach they say they go to bell
at easter week
and our city is a we have about 18 000
population
and they estimated that we had about 35
000 young people last year
we think that the problem wouldn't be so
great if we could change this
into a and a family week at easter time
and make it a family holiday let the
kids stay home and just the parents come
down here
no we like the parents with the children
well it's a big problem all over the
country and i said you don't have any
solution
however there's one thing i'd like to
say to all the teenagers who are tuned
in right now
how can you study algebra and listen to
me at the same time
then uh who are you again uh bert
stewart
fate stewart huh where are you from
brady i was born
uh and raised about 30 miles south of
raleigh north carolina on a tobacco farm
got y'all oh that's in virginia isn't it
no it's north carolina
i thought they raised tobacco in
virginia well that's
where do they raise the filters do you
know well that would be a good business
to get into
well uh did you become a tobacco farmer
i understand they're endorsing doctors
now
no graduate after i became a
man of my own i left home and did
various things i
worked in the service station i was a
quartermaster on a
freight boat in the chesapeake bay
bouncer nightclubs furniture salesman
short order cook various other things
wow you have had
a varied life haven't you huh you were
restless huh
yes you might call it there well i will
did you ever try going into business for
yourself babe
yes i went in the business when i came
out of the air force
and we were green island yesterday
uh on one occasion i went on the
uh tangent trying to sell
chicken box lunches to a football
audience in
[Music]
the university of north carolina georgia
was playing up there and had about 40
000 people and i figured i could sell
chicken bucks lunches to all of them and
i
what happened fixed up 2 000 chicken box
lunches and arrived at a football game
just two hours too late so i was stuck
with 2 000 chicken monsters
what'd you do with these two thousand
staples chickens did you sell them to an
army navy star
no i'm afraid that they were spoiled and
had to uh get rid of them
what what was your next business venture
bud if this keeps up i may voice into
tears
i'll make him sink me mr joe sink reamer
as well that's more like it
what's a sink reamer the sink reamer is
a device
for adapting an old cast enamel sink
so that a lady can have a garbage
disposal installed in the sink without
having to take the sink out and replace
it with a new one
well how did you happen to get into this
kind of business
well i saw the operation being performed
and i
was interested in it it looked uh like
it would be
something to get into
and i uh it's a nice messy thought isn't
it
i did a bit of research on it and it
found that 40
of all the garbage disposals were being
sold in the sold in the nation
being sold here in california i'm glad
we have so much garbage here and
you know new york may have the catskills
in minnesota may have the lakes but
we've got more garbage than any other
other state can make that statement
well this has indeed been an experience
talking to you too and i want to see how
much money you can make you're going to
play your bet your life
remember we start you off with a hundred
dollars if you miss a question you lose
half your bankroll
no matter what it amounts to at the time
uh is that clear yeah
okay now you select this biblical quiz
and remember the more the question is
right the harder it is
what do you want to start with and
remember your partners and talk it over
one answer between let's start with
dollars a hundred dollars well a hundred
dollars two dollars would be all right
okay in the genesis account of the
creation on what day was the land made
second date
come on kids second date no i'm sorry it
was the third day
you lost half your original hundred
dollars you now have fifty dollars
nine ninety dollars in which book of the
bible are the ten commandments found
leviticus no i'm sorry it's the exodus
that's just
[Music]
oh
lost half you're 25 and i'll have 1250.
well they're gamesters
you're going to take the 70. what is
referred to as the decalogue
talk it over
rebecca is that the
first 10 books of the year no
first 10 books it got me in tv
no answer no comment was the ten
commandments
you wind up with uh cents
uh i'm gonna give you one question to
get it right we bring your winnings up
to 25.
what time is it when both hands point to
12.
all the clock is right
now here are some more scenes from
groucho's european trip this summer
i am in lobel's forest and this is one
vehicle it wouldn't be safe to hold a
candle to
speaking of holding candles the great
new desoto for 1955 is coming your way
so don't you miss it
that's the brand new desoto on display
wednesday november 17th
your very first chance to see this
stylish new desoto
wednesday november 17th here i am in
london
and of course they don't speak english
very well over here
and this spelling is rather curious but
this is just a reminder to be around
when we show you the brand new grand new
desoto for 1955
for the very first time on this show yes
really we are
in any language that date is wednesday
november 17th
don't miss it your first chance to see
the stunning new de soto
well just before we went on the air our
studio audience selected mr bill early
to be on the show groucho
his partner is a public relations
consultant miss joan rosenfall so folks
you quinn please and meet
rachel marks welcome to your bet your
life say the secret word and divide the
hundred dollars it's a common way
something you find around the house
mr bill hailey and joan rosenthal joan
where are you from
well i live in a suburb of chicago
called glencoe illinois
glencoe how old are you joan 26
26 well young look that's a lovely age
especially if you happen to be 38.
[Music]
is it miss or mrs uh well i'm afraid
it's myth
well if you're afraid i'm not surprised
it's missing
you're very attractive now what is the
reason you're single joan
nice looking girl young girl pretty hair
teeth
i don't really know i keep asking myself
why am i still single
well stop asking yourself and ask
somebody else
get better results that way
would you like to get married yes i'd
like to
why any particular reason well i'd like
to have family
have you have you looked for a husband
yeah i've been lucky
well you're honest about it most girls
when they're not married even if they're
attractive they say no i don't want to
get married
where have you looked specifically for
well i've looked in chicago and
new york los angeles
baltimore kansas city st
louis you've got to make a dragnet out
[Music]
i bet you've had a lot of proposals joan
well
you've had a number of them and you just
haven't found anybody that you like yeah
and i admire you for that
because most girls at 26 are so panicky
they're afraid they're not going to get
a fellow
that they grab the first yokel that
comes along
and i i admire you for having high
standards well thank you
and you've uh i bet you'll wind up with
just the boy you want well thank you
very much
uh mr harley you look like a fellow gets
around
i don't know what you get around but you
look like
you look like a fellow gets around maybe
you could help joe and find a a spouse
what sort of work do you do i buy cattle
for armory company
[Music]
well i doubt if you can do joe on any
good
oh i buy almost anywhere i can find them
we go out looking for them our uh
on the highway oh no our uh our main
buying office is at the stockyards union
stockyard
what do you do with these cows after you
buy them well we come home
no we slaughter them dress them and
sell them hope to get our money back
you've got to
uh to get your money back you can't miss
them too far the tolerance is supposed
to be about one half
one percent what do you mean by that
well
uh if uh for instance uh
the cattle have uh some water in that
you don't detect they can drink quite a
lot of water so
water stock there yeah it'd be watered
stocks they're forty i had some water
stock in wall street once is it anything
like that
it's about the same in the same category
40 pounds of water that you don't see at
20 cents a pound is uh eight dollars
that's more than we hope to make when we
buy them you see and we don't want to
make that mistake
well how do you know if the if the car
was waterlogged or not well
i'm around all night you see they're not
there it'll be all right if you could
but you don't already know
you shake them see if they make a noise
they can conceal it pretty well
now uh they have four stomachs you know
well can't you shake them no they
they're a little big for that
let's get back to you joan what sort of
work do you do well i travel around and
talk to women about
their hair and advise them on what kind
of permanents to use and
how to groom their hair home permanent
yes you know how to avoid falling here
well no no you step nimbly to one side
[Applause]
well is the home payment and a fairly
new invention joan
well um tony has really made it a mass
market product but actually uh we've
heard that women have been trying to
curl their hair for
years and we've heard that cleopatra
even tried to give herself a home
permanent
she took her hair and rolled it on a
twig and then took
it off you mean no just from her right
on her head and then took the mud from
the nile and
plastered it on the twig and of course
when it dried she had curly hair but it
was a little messy
well they were all plastered on that
pods weren't they
joan i could tell you a story right now
that would curl your hair and you
wouldn't eat anymore
well enough of this talk about hair and
cattle that's where you bet your life
man
we start you off with a hundred dollars
but if you miss a question you lose half
your total is that clear
that's clear at this point in the race
for the three thousand dollars
the first couple leads with six dollars
twenty five cents
the secret word is chair fail your price
question has nothing to do with the quiz
but answer it anyway
have you read any good books lately no
not just recently no
well it's not important i just want to
be sure the next book you read is one
about
one of the most fascinating charming
clever characters in all literature
you know where that is me
george would you mind telling him about
it my modesty prevents me from going any
further
a skeptic over there that's going to get
fired
it seems that uh groucho's son arthur
has written a book
entitled life with groucho published by
simon schuster at sale at all bookstores
all over the country considering the
subject matter i think my son arthur has
done a very good job on this and i think
you'll enjoy it
you'll see the seamier side of grocho
all right well that's why you bet your
life man how much you're going to start
with
you start with 70. 70 or 80 whatever you
want
80. all right 80 what do you call the
wife of an oil
e-a-r-l countess
easy the questions a little the money
harder the question the bigger the dough
okay okay how much 90 90. if a pentagon
has five sides how many sides
does a dexagon have decagon
decagos baby dog d-e-c-a-g-o-n
decagon
[Music]
[Applause]
how many acres in a square mile oh i
know that one
well you're sure you're in a cattle
business yeah but i can't go up to
square mile talking elsewhere
a square mile square mile square mile
how many acres
640. 640 is absolutely right
and you now have 370 dollars
now what are you going to go we got to
be careful is your last chance to be the
other couple
yeah seventy dollars what was the name
of the venetian traveler who was famous
for his journeys through asia
and for his dealings with kubla khan
ukraine marco polo marco
[Music]
you'll have a hustle by me
before we go ahead i want to show you
another scene from my european trip
this is an old roman tradition that was
started by the boys who clean these
fountains
but don't you throw your money away
don't even look at another car until you
see the great new desoto for 1955
coming your way soon soon is right
groucho
wednesday november 17th is your first
chance to see the stunning new desoto
for 1955.
wednesday november 17th forgot
who's next i was just going to tell you
we invited what was the name of that
book again
which book uh look at my son
which book you benedict
uh life was brocco wow you've been badly
trained
yeah i was going to say uh
groucho we invited some high school boys
from a special school to our show
tonight just before we went in the air
our studio audience selected carol hall
to be on the show
his partner is a special guest miss
indra davey
so folks you come in please and meet
groucho marx
welcome welcome to the desoto plymouth
dealer say the secret word and divide a
hundred dollars
it's a common word something you find
around the house
indra debbie is that right davey davey
yeah and carol hall
that's a very unusual outfit you have on
indra is it a smock or a kimono or what
do you call it
neither it is a saree a sorry well you
don't to be sorry you can wear anything
you like in this show
why are you sorry uh indra i'm not sorry
no but i'm very sorry oh well why do you
wear sorry
because i lived in india very long and i
adopted india's my motherland and i like
the indian
attire it's five and a half yards of a
long material
and you drop drape yourself into it i
see it's charming huh
thank you which part of india were you
were you born in
i was born in riga alaska and latvia
isn't that that's in europe isn't it yes
nothing to do with india no well i
am confused i thought you were born in
india no on the buma road
no on the buy my shave or something
now uh what is what is your name uh
carol hall
carol hall huh sounds like an apartment
house
how old are you uh carol 16 16.
how did you meet your wife uh carol he's
not married
you're not married actually i assumed
you weren't married but you see i asked
everybody that question and
i just didn't want you to feel slight in
it
however if you insist on giving me a
shifty answer that's your business
[Music]
i i assume you go to school that carol
yes sir
where do you hibernate i go to boys
republic at chino
the boys republic what is that is that a
did a group of you youngsters get
together and secede in the union
well it's a self-governing school and
farm for boys which have never
had a real home
you mentioned something about a farm do
you sell butter and eggs to the public
no sir uh we make the dullarobia
christmas wreath
for most of the profit no i see
what do these wreaths look like well
they've got seven or
eight different types of pods and fruit
mixed in together
real fruit yes you can eat this fruit
yes
how much you get for these wreaths well
the reefs run from five dollars to nine
dollars
well i'll i'll take three of those will
you send me three though
take one for my master one for my dame
and one for the redhead that lives
across the street
now mrs debbie let's get back to you do
you have a job
well i am teaching yoga yoga isn't he a
baseball player
he's with that teen that used to win the
planet all the time
what would they call the yonkers
[Music]
yankees or something like that no
i'm teaching yoga exercises in my studio
on sunset and i'm lecturing on yoga
well what is yoga indra can you tell us
in a few words
well yoga is a system
of physical mental and spiritual
training
which originated in india and
the yogis believe that the deep
breathing
is the basis for their training
and when you breathe in they believe in
breathing in
the cosmic energy
you breathe deep in other words oh yes
it is a deep breathing
well that might be all right in india
but if you breathe dp your life will
wind up in a cemetery
i got up last week and went to the
window and took 10 deep breaths and went
back to bed for three days
well there must be more to yoga than
just just breathing isn't it
yeah could you tell us some more about
it well there may be a lot of yogi eyes
out front tonight
if i took up yoga what would i have to
do well if you were to become a yogi
you would first afford to give up your
cigar
[Music]
i don't smoke much i just smoked during
the day that's all
well i could give up smoking what else
would i have to well
relinquish a yogi would not drink
if you take drinks you'll have to give
them up too
i don't drink much got all of us do it
oh no much more
there's more to it let's get it huh
you give up fried food for it fried
foods or something else again huh
now let's play an old-fashioned american
game called you bet your life
in the race for the three thousand
dollars the second couple is now leading
with four hundred
forty dollars all right you selected
science and medicine remember the more
the question is worth the harder the
question is
what are you going to start with you'll
see all of it
uh hundred dollars all of it all right
that's the hardest one the bigger the
sum the harder the question oh we'll
take half of it then all right
what do you call the loss of memory the
loss of memory
memory if you lose your memory what is
that called
amnesia that's right amnesia
if a weatherman wanted to measure
atmospheric pressure what instrument
would he use
talk it over
thermometer no i'm sorry it's a
barometer you had 150 you lost half you
now have 75
all right i don't get discouraged now
what are you going to try this time
30 30. what do you call the device that
is twisted around the arm or leg to stop
bleeding
[Music]
tourniquet take it is right
you all have 105 now what are you going
to try
40 hunger the green coloring matter in
plants is called what
clutter field chlorophyll is right
[Music]
you lined up with 145 thanks and good
luck from the desoto plymouth dealers
well thank you
that means you miss joan rosenthal and
mr early with 440 dollars in just one
minute
get the chance of the desoto plymouth 3
000 questions
well let's take a minute to get away
from it all and back to italy
you may think these boys are all statues
but you're wrong
they're just waiting until they can get
their first look at the stylish new
desoto
why don't you pull up a pedestal and
join us until you can get your first
chance to see the stylish desoto for
1955.
tell them when george wednesday november
17th
that's your very first chance to see the
1955 desoto
don't miss it wednesday november 17th
i just gave that battleship 10 minutes
to get out of town
incidentally this is about the only road
you won't be able to travel in the brand
new wonderful desoto for 1955.
it's coming your way wednesday november
17th the stylish 1955 desoto
so watch for it wednesday november 17th
here's our winning couple ground show
miss rosenthal and mr early
all set for the desoto plymouth three
thousand dollar question
all right here we go for three thousand
dollars i'll give you 15 seconds to
decide on a single answer between you
think carefully and please no help in
the audience here it is
one of the most famous buildings in the
world was the temple of athena
built around 400 years bc on the
acropolis of athens
for three thousand dollars by what name
do we know this famous temple
parts of which still remain talk it over
i know
don't worry james you win thousand
dollars between you don't worry you want
to get married pretty soon
plus how much in the quiz yours uh 440
dollars in the quiz now the how much do
they each uh have now george well all
the guys they have
thirty four hundred and forty dollars
and split that right down that doesn't
happen what is it george i have no idea
well uh thanks so what are you going to
do with all that money i don't know
i have no idea and you what do you i
think i'll give it to my favorite
charity that's my wife
well uh congratulations from the desoto
plymouth dealers of america you bet your
life
[Music]
and now here he is the one the only
[Music]
well here i'm again with three thousand
dollars for one of our couples
let him say the secret word uh they'll
win a hundred dollars the way tonight is
clock
okay doc you're excused uh groucho we
invited some dancing instructors to the
program tonight
and just before we went in the air our
studio audience selected miss anne
reardon her partner is mr bill eddy so
folks would you come in please and meet
groucho marx welcome to the desoto
plymouth dealers
say the sacred word and divide a hundred
dollars it's a common word something you
see
every day and reading and bill eddy
and you're a dancing instructor it says
here yes
where are you from annie well i was
originally from st louis and i lived in
chicago but i've been out here since i
was 12 years old
in other words annie doesn't live there
anymore are you single yes
i hope i'm correct i'm guessing you're
not engaged am i correct yes
are you busy tonight yeah
you say yes yes tomorrow night yes
you said yes four times in a row you
realize that yes
apparently the answer is still no
[Music]
bill eddie that's you um yes i don't
care how many times you say yes
bill are you married no engaged no
if you found the right girl would you
like to get married yes i think i would
can you support a wife bill well
reasonably well
you're walking on quicksand though
where do you work i work for the bank of
america in glendale maine office
you work at the bank of america and
congratulations
this is better than striking oil
bill what do you think of anne and be
candid as you like you know you're among
friends
well i'm such short a queen [ __ ] but i
think she's a very lovely and charming
girl
i haven't seen a banker pay that much
interest since the boom of 87.
[Music]
what do you do with this bank bill i'm a
lending officer
oh i accept applications for loans from
individuals companies investigate their
credit background
employment verify their salary and
length of employment
etc would you lend me any money
well are you gainfully employed
i won't know till a show comes out
[Music]
what else would you want to know about
me well i'd have to know your salary
how long you've been employed your
prospects for future employment
what you wanted the money for
etc you know what i want the money
i've often wondered about banks with all
that money around how do they know you
fellas won't take home a few samples
well the bank conducts a very thorough
investigation and
ascertains our honesty before we're
employed
that's not important they better make
sure your honors after they hire
isn't there some little way an employee
can make an honest mistake like slipping
a couple of thousand under his toupee
[Music]
well be honest isn't that oh a teller
could go out to lunch and take a couple
grand with him and
not come back but wouldn't be long
before his absence was noticed and
he'd be caught eventually yes but by
this time he'd had the lunch
well apparently you've been giving this
some thought anyhow haven't you
and you may have your honeymoon in rio
de janeiro
bill by the way i know the bank of
america is a very big bank it happens
i've got 32
there myself just between us what
assurance do i have that this money is
safe
well uh all deposits up to ten thousand
dollars are assured
are insured by the federal government in
washington that's my guarantee
yes have you heard that the federal
government is about 280 billion dollars
in the hole
that's after they collected crosby
stations
[Music]
let's talk about you ann where do you do
your dancing the arthur murray studio on
wilshire boulevard oh arthur mario i
know
i know him very well as a matter of fact
i was on the show a few weeks ago did
you see it
no you didn't huh what are some of the
common faults you find among men dances
besides their desire to
stay you to the back porch as soon as
possible all among
many faults they're the kind that dance
or what we call side saddle you know off
to the side so they can peer around your
shoulder
why do they want to look around your
shoulder what's going on back there
[Music]
see where they're going and uh oh the
kind that
oh the talkers you know talkers they
tell you that their wife doesn't
understand them no
they count all the time they count yeah
slow slow
quick quick slow slow quick quick all
the time in your ear
and you think you could teach this guy
anything oh i'm sure i can
thank you bill uh
when do you think you get together with
us just to kind of talk things over huh
well uh we discussed this a little bit
before the show and we decided we want
any money why we might get together
after the show and
talk it over a little bit this was uh
you knew this all the time when i was
talking to her at the beginning yes
like a cat playing with a mouse
once she gave the right answers it was
more like a rat playing with a mouse
you two have already gotten together huh
well i swung
gosh i'm swan and years
apparently he doesn't spend all this
time foreclosing mortgages
well you're a very effective couple and
anna bill has trouble carrying you
across the threshold
after you're married don't worry do what
i do let the bank of america carry them
i let's see how much money you can win
you beat our other couples you get a
chance at the big money now let's see
uh you select a general information quiz
and remember the more the question is
worth the harder it is
okay okay seventy seventy done
all right in a matrimonial a general
information quiz in a matrimonial sense
what is a benedict
no that's a married man usually newly
married
well that's single i'm sorry
[Music]
now uh what question do you want you
still got lots of chances
80 60 100 60 60.
what kind of a business establishment
would you associate with a mortar
and pestle it's a plaster
thing okay a plaster
either a drugstore or a farmer or a
pharmacy that's the thing he grinds it
up in
that's right yeah well we're not doing
what's it doing oh well
so now what do you want let's go 150.
50 50. according to mother goose who
went to bed with one shoe on
this will have to be yours
[Music]
see a married man with children would
know this
[Music]
well i know it's little little dumpling
my son john went to bed with a stockings
on once you're walking one shoe on did a
little empty mice and john you see you
have to have children
remember that now then it's your last
chance to beat the other couples what
question are you going to go for should
we go lower chopper penguin
80. eighty dollars eighty dollars what
do you call a freshman at west point
please queen cleve is right at least you
have eighty dollars
[Music]
thanks and good luck to the sort of
plymouth
[Music]
this is the california desert a real
desert of deep loose sand
treacherous soft shoulders blistering
heat
and this is a lovely 1954 desoto
automatic on the desert road
now watch we're driving this desoto
automatic out into the sand
in an ordinary car it would be almost
impossible to move or steer in this type
of sand
watch this though the world's newest and
finest fully automatic transmission
power flight transmission lets the
desoto automatic
accelerate smoothly steadily evenly with
great power even here and steering is
simple
even through heavy treacherous sand with
desoto
full-time power steering the power
steering that works for
you all the time makes turning the
steering wheel as easy as dialing a
phone
there are hundreds of reasons why this
lovely 1954 desoto
deserves the name automatic reasons you
should discover for yourself
go to your desoto plymouth dealer soon
see
and drive the beautiful stylish
distinctive
1954 desoto automatic it's available in
two full series
the mighty 170 horsepower fire dome
eight
and the brilliant power master six
convince yourself
that this year desoto put you ahead
automatically well now we have a young
lady with an interesting job groucho her
name is shirley lestell and her partner
is mr charles sandoval so folks would
you come in please and meet
groucho marx well welcome welcome for
the desoto plymouth dealers there's one
of them out front
say the secret word and you'll divide a
hundred dollars it's a it's a common
word something you see every day
let's see charles uh sandoval and
shirley lester like
you're surely yeah yes sir uh shirley
you don't mind my calling you shirley
answer your acquaintance do you
not at all what did you say
i said i don't mind you calling me
shirley do you always talk that way
well i guess so my voice uh didn't
change that i grew up
oh it's like your voice didn't change
otherwise i'd be calling you sam
[Music]
now uh how old are you shirley 25 25 yes
mr charles sandoval is that that's you
yes or no
i can't help but notice that patch over
your eye is that anything serious
no sir the bright lights uh hurt my eyes
oh
is your chin sensitive to lie to uh
naughty
[Music]
where are you from originally i was born
in the uh city of san salvador in the
republic of salvador
oh well why did you leave san salvador
did you get tired of bananas
no there was a revolution in 1929 and my
father thought it would be a good time
to leave the country
you mean he let a little revolution
scare him was he a coward
no certainly not he was a president
well the job blew up in his face i don't
blame him for quitting there's not much
chance for advancement in a job like
that
shirley let's get back to you there's
one question i haven't asked
you you are married huh yes yeah do you
have any outside interest shirley or do
you spend all your time keeping house
oh no i work for a paper mate pen
company i have for the last two years
oh well what do you do as a paper mate
well
um right now i'm uh uh
in uh doing the uh first assembly i've
done um
fillers first assembly final assembly
inspection
now what's a fella a filler is this and
that's the fella you were married to i
don't mean him
well a filler in a paper made pin is the
is the uh
the little inside that you write with
that's what you buy when you run out of
ink but it doesn't happen very often
[Music]
only when you're right i guess sir
about 70 000 words there there is i
don't know that many words well
suppose i were to buy one how would i
know if it was any good assuming that i
did buy one
well it would be good if you bought it
because each pin is is
tested we got uh 20 girls test them
underwater
no on paper we have
20 girls that that write johnson all day
long
johnson must get an awful lot of mail
huh
why do they write johnson i happen to
know johnson he can't even read
besides that he's a married man does mrs
johnson
uh get wind of this no but johnson has
all the necessary loops and swirls and
straight lines
if you think johnson has him you should
see mrs johnson
[Music]
but i'm sure you'd be much more
interested in winning some money
wouldn't you that's right so let's play
your bet your life beat our other
couples you'll get a chance at the big
money later
the banker and the dancing instructor
won eighty dollars the secret word is
clock
all right now let's see how much money
you can make you selected science and
medicine
remember the more the question is worth
the harder it is
now what do you want ten dollar one
eighty hundred
talk it over your partners
sixty please what is another word for
vertigo
vertigo dizziness that's right
offer a good start with sixty dollars
bye job that was right charlie
now what one do you want
okay seventy what do you call the
colored part of the eye
the pupil the colored part of the eye is
the retina
right now the boat's gone charlie it's
the iris
you still have sixty dollars however now
you have sixty dollars
now what do you want
[Music]
to try and trade we'll try the 80 80.
okay what is the common word for
clavicle
clavicle collarbone that's right
you now have 140 now what do you want to
try
is your last chance to beat the other
couple 90 90 90
what is the science that deals with
birds called ornithology
that is absolutely correct
and you wind up with 230 dollars
thanks and good luck to the desoto
plymouth dealers that one colorado
[Music]
now before we proceed i have a telegram
here i want to read
this is the groucho marx nbc hollywood
now we rarely do this this is the wire
500 radio and tv
editors participating in the annual
motion picture herald
500 radio and tv editors participating
in the annual motion picture herald
and train magazine poll have voted
george fenneman the best announcer in
television
uh thanks gentlemen thanks george get
your head out of the clouds and tell us
who's next
all right roger we have a guest tonight
from down under he's mister
and don't ask for more money you're just
wasting your time
we know as a matter of fact we may cut
your salad
we got you'll have these in chromiums
what eat comiums
we have a guest tonight
this fellow went to stanford and i went
to reform school
e-c-o-m-i-u-m-s
something like that we uh
we have a guest
look it up when you get home i'll do
that for sure look on the e e
we have a guest tonight uh groucho from
down under mr uh ethel smyrden where is
he in the subway
well uh you'll see in just a minute i
think mr ethel smyrden is his name
and his partner is a hollywood pioneer
miss mary sackett so folks you come in
please and meet
rachel marks
now you got a boxy welcome for the
desoto plymouth dealer say the secret
word and you'll divide a hundred dollars
it's a common word something you see
every day
mr aphil smartin oh come now you just
made that update no no no
my name is apple that's a scotch thing
hmm
why aren't you in a gas tank oh well
apple you see is the
male equivalent for ethel the girl's
name
oh how about smaiden smitten well
they're kind of a nameless movie
that's old english devonshire my
grandfather came from south devon
oh now where are you from mr smayden i'm
from auckland
oakland well that's right across the bay
from san francisco isn't it
no groucho auckland a-u-c-k
l-a-n-d
i don't care how you spell it it's still
across the baby
why do you assume this uh dialect if
you're from oakland
well actually have you ever heard of new
zealand
new zealand have you ever
heard of ecomium
[Music]
well that's right across the bay from
oakland same place
now let's talk to you uh okay mr sanchez
this second you please
miss second thank you i'm terribly sorry
no you may be sorry but i'm not
this hasn't been an easy day for me
well i'm glad you're not sorry uh mr
sackett
i uh you're a spencer huh i'm a sister
from choice
choice is that near oakland
where were you born uh connecticut
in connecticut man across the alley from
the town hall
offices to town park where the town she
got back from the backyard
the family are shooting a i'm a grand
dad's connecticut seedless tobacco farm
10 marshmallow sprinkling mass 16 from
hartford connecticut
and if you dispose of the cigar thank
you
[Applause]
we don't
i'm not going to light it can i just
hold it no i don't like to lose
something
how do you feel about me mary oh you
look all right perhaps if you leave
cigar alone
boy am i getting pushed around tonight
how old are you mary 78 years 78
[Applause]
you're certainly spry and chipper mary
how do you account for the fact that
you're so young looking at 78 what do
you do to keep them conditioned
oh you don't smoke cigars huh
i need a drink no smoke
and i take breathing exercises
could you breathe a little for us
hey uh how about stepping over here mary
and uh
and do a few of those exercises for us
huh
this is a slow breath
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
well that was quite a demonstration you
put there uh mary
you what else do you do to keep healthy
i walk and
talk yes you talk very well and
got me out of a cigar
[Music]
well let's play your bet your life man
you beat our other couples you'll get a
chance at the big money
our second couple leads with 230 dollars
now you two have to decide on one answer
between you on all these things let's
see how much money you can make you
select the geography
and remember the more the question is
work the harder it is
now what question do you want to start
with i think it will take about
number eight how's that number right the
80 dollar one is that all right with you
all right if whatever's right with him
it'll be all right for me i expected
what country does greenland belong
austin uh no
it's denmark all right now you got three
more chances
say 70. 70. what is the capital city of
alaska
anchorage no it's juno
what one do you want now
come on hmm do you want now 50. let's
get a big one you get
nothing to lose so far yeah we'll get a
hundred a hundred we're gonna get
together
what is the largest state east of the
mississippi
well i just now you're from united
states what's the largest state
east of the mississippi
texas isn't it
oh he's not just like a man well it's
georgia
that's your last chance to beat the
other couple how much you're going to
bet
you want a ninety dollar one a ten
dollar one no we'll get a hat
well it's all right with you if we get a
hundred that's all right no you've had a
ah all right we'll go 90. all right all
right in which of our states do you find
show shown falls s-h-o-s-h-o-n-e
they're higher than niagara come on it's
yours i don't know
come on what do you think i bet
no but this is uh this is in the west
and they're higher than niagara oh
higher than niagara that's an idaho
that's right
[Applause]
thanks and good luck to the soda
[Music]
plymouth
that means our second couple shirley
lastelle and her partner charles
sandoval
with two hundred and thirty dollars in
just one moment get the chance at the
desoto plymouth three
thousand dollar question before they
come back george i want you to give our
friends the word on the groucho special
used car campaign
the groucho special campaign is a
tremendous success
friends take a good look at this sticker
so many people have gone to their desoto
plymouth dealer for
a good used car and said groucho sent me
that your desoto plymouth dealer is
doing something extra for groucho's fans
he's taken the best used car bargains he
has
and put this sticker on the windshield
marking the car a groucho special
these groucho specials are unusually
good cars
especially priced to make them the
hottest values in town
you see the overwhelming popularity of
the 1954 desoto
means that your desoto plymouth dealer
has obtained some really great used cars
in trade
many of them are late model one owner
cars the very best will be the ones he
selects as groucho specials
so don't miss out on this great
opportunity
tomorrow first thing go to your desoto
plymouth dealers
and look for the used cars with this
sticker the groucho special sticker
sign of a used car that's a really
outstanding buy
there may be one that's just the car
you've been looking for
it's the groucho special sticker your
dealer's way of showing you a real
used-car bag
and when you drive in tell them groucho
sent you
groucho here comes our winning couple
the man from san salvador and shirley
lestell all set for the desoto plymouth
three thousand dollar question
right in there all right for three
thousand dollars to give you 15 seconds
to decide on a single answer think
carefully and please no help in the
audience here it is
one of the most famous of greek legends
concerns jason
and his quest for the golden fleece the
sailors who accompany jason had many
wonderful adventures
for three thousand dollars what were
these sailors called it is a word still
used frequently
[Music]
what is the answer you two have decided
upon argo counts
argonauts is absolutely right
three thousand dollars and that was a
tough question how much do they win the
quiz george uh
230 dollars in the quiz which gives them
30 to
32 30. congratulations from the more
than 3
000 to soda plymouth dealers from coast
to coast you bet you like
um